you
welcome my name is Scott Malone I'm
editor with Reuters in Boston and I'll
be your moderator today today's program
is now are long and it's a collaboration
of the forum at the Harvard th Chan
School of Public Health and Reuters this
event has also been organized with the
Center for Global tobacco control and
the Department of Social and Behavioral
Sciences at the Harvard chance cool the
debate around the role of e-cigarettes
and a regulation has roiled the public
health community will review ye
cigarettes and other electronic nicotine
delivery systems or en ds's products are
controversial then we will take a look
at some policy questions related to
their regulation will take odd questions
from the online audience as well as you
here in the studio questions for the
panelists for those of you online can be
emailed to the forum at HSPH harvard edu
or tweeted to at forum HSPH using the
hashtag hashtag e-cigs forum you can
also participate in the live chat
discussion that's happening online at
the forum site right now today's
panelists starting from my immediate
right arvon Reese lecture on Social and
Behavioral Sciences in the Department of
Social and Behavioral Sciences an
interim director of the center of global
tobacco control at the Harvard chance
cool then we have Howard Koh professor
of the practice of public health
leadership at the Harvard chance cool
and former assistant secretary of health
for the US Department of Health and
Human Services and K fish Vishnu otha
professor of health communication in the
Department of Social and Behavioral
Sciences at the Harvard Chan school and
in the McGraw Patterson Center for
population sciences at the danaher
farber cancer institute in addition
joining us remotely we had Kenneth
Warner distinguished University
professor of Public Health and former
dean of the university of michigan
school of public health and david
hammond associate professor at the
University of Waterloo School of Public
Health and health systems and former
adviser to the World Health Organization
for the framework convention on tobacco
control with that I'd like to kick the
conversation off and turn it over to
Yvonne thanks very much Scott well we're
witnessing an event with enormous
implications for Public Health with the
advent of a new and very aggressive
e-cigarette industry that's quickly
shaved a three billion dollar market
share having having reached that level
from virtually nothing six or seven
years ago on the one hand we've seen
tobacco control efforts in the United
States and indeed globally have had an
enormous impact we've seen the
prevalence of smoking in the u.s.
declined by about half in the past 50
years thanks to efforts that have helped
to restrict advertising and marketing
that have resulted in better health
communication of including tobacco
product warning labels we've seen
restrictions on age access mostly
restricting access to youth aged under
18 we've seen very effective
implications of price control through
excise taxes and recently the FDA have
gained regulatory authority over tobacco
products which has far-reaching
implications on how those tobacco
products might be regulated to to
enhance or to protect the public health
but meanwhile e-cigarettes or ends as
God's got suggested have recently become
quite ubiquitous and e-cigarettes offer
an opportunity to reduce the harm
associated with tobacco use because they
don't involve combustion of tobacco
instead they deliver nicotine which is
suspended in a propylene glycol of
glycerin reservoir which is heated and
volatilized and then made available to
the consumer through through puffing the
vapor e-cigarettes may provide an
enormous opportunity for the public
health community to reduce the harm
associated with tobacco use based on the
notion that we that if the smokers of
conventional cigarettes switch from a
tobacco cigarette to an e-cigarette they
may reduce the harm associated with the
use of that product on the other hand
though we're concerned in the tobacco
control community that the advent of
e-cigarettes being largely unregulated
may undermine many of the gains we've
made around reducing the prevalence of
tobacco use over the past fifty years e
cigarettes currently are using
strategies that have not been used with
tobacco products for many years
including use of TV and radio to
advertise there are poor if any
restrictions on youth access
products are being marketed targeted to
youth making health claims which have
not so far been supported as well as
claims around cessation have also seen
proliferation of candy flavored or
exotic flavored cigarettes including
flavors such as bubblegum and gummy bear
which are very appealing to youth so
we're concerned about the potential for
youth to embrace a new generation of use
to embrace tobacco products through the
use of e-cigarettes and and and so
undermined gains that we've made in
tobacco control okay so I think we see
an element of controversy there for sure
and with that Ken we'd like to turn it
over to you could you speak a little bit
about how the public health community
view view of these issues cated the
public health community specifically the
tobacco control community unlike any
that I've seen in my 40 years in this
field the only possible exception that
was the argument over the master
settlement agreement in the 1990s I
think Vaughn characterized it very
nicely we really have two camps on
opposite ends of the spectrum on the one
side are the more traditional forces of
Public Health these are the folks who
are focusing on the concerns about
e-cigarettes and electronic nicotine
delivery systems they're worried about
those they're also focused laser light
on the effects on kids and they don't
seem to be thinking very much about the
potential benefits for adult smokers on
the other side of the spectrum or the
folks we refer to as the harm reduction
asst these are the people who are
looking at smokers who have not quit
seemed either unable or unwilling to
quit to give up their nicotine the
nicotine replacement products haven't
worked for them and they thought in this
camp is it products like e-cigarettes
may constitute viable alternatives for
these folks we know that these
alternative products when compared to
the dangers of combustible tobacco
products are dramatically less dangerous
there's just no question about that
that's not to say that they're all only
the same so
are exposing people to toxic substances
that are not in others um what I think
is missing here is a strong middle
ground the issues surrounding kids and
worrying about the effects on kids are
important and we have to pay attention
to that but I think a lot of people
among what I've referred to as the more
traditional public health community are
focusing almost exclusively on that and
we don't know a whole lot about the
implications of kids use of e-cigarettes
we do know the vast majority of
e-cigarette uses among people who are
either smokers or were smokers I'm
talking about kids here very few a very
tiny proportion of never smokers have
used e-cigarettes in the last 30 days
and the y on the other side of it we've
got these folks who think that this is
sort of the the solution to all of our
problems it's not that either the harm
reduction camp is missing then they
ignore the risks to kids so it's it's
it's been a very frustrating it's been a
very vitriolic conversation so certainly
there's there's no amount of tension
there for sure with that I think we'll
bring it around to you Howard and can
you talk a little bit about some of the
challenges we're seeing at the state and
federal level for regulating
e-cigarettes sure it's very important to
put this forum into proper context so
just to remind this audience in 2009 the
FDA gained unprecedented authority to
regulate tobacco for the first time
without authority applies only to
cigarettes smokeless tobacco and
roll-your-own tobacco so left completely
unregulated our products like
e-cigarettes dissolvable 'he's cigars
and hookahs for example and so in that
space currently we have absolutely no
standards and no regulations for
e-cigarettes with respect to dimensions
like production design manufacturing
quality safety and very importantly
advertising and marketing now just
exactly a year ago april 2014 the fda
put out proposed rules to extend their
authority over those other
forms of tobacco including e-cigarettes
and that's called the deeming process
there's been a comment period for
deeming and we're hoping the FDA will
come out with its final rule very very
soon those proposed rules put forward
provisions such as prohibiting sales to
minors requiring warning labels
preventing free sample giveaways a
themes like that but very importantly
did not address the advertising and
marketing dimensions we're being told
that that will require yet another FDA
rulemaking process so in this void
states and municipalities have stepped
up we now know that over 40 states ban e
cigarette sales to minors but only about
three states prohibit e-cigarette use in
public places as part of upholding clean
indoor air so you have a very active
discussion on going right now we're
waiting for final rules from the FDA to
come forward but in the interim we know
that e-cigarettes are very much a
double-edged sword in the long run they
could be a very powerful form of harm
reduction if proven to be effective
through good studies with the short term
we have tremendous concern about uptake
by non-smokers by pregnant women by kids
especially and the proliferation of
flavored cigarettes in particular is
something that is a great concern to
everyone okay and certainly the the use
by new smokers raises the question of
marketing and the company's outreach to
them are and certainly one area under
discussion now is the role of regulation
in marketing e-cigarettes with that
let's take a look at a few
advertisements for e-cigarettes
for us smokers times have changed
but a few things remain the same
our desire to explore to adventure
to roam without boundaries
with blue we can still be ourselves
after all this country was founded on
free will embrace it
chase it
blu ecigs
take back your freedom
you
this is not your mother's cigarette slim
sleek
sparkling break free from the past it's
smoke free odor free and stigma free
coordinating colors straight off the
runway
eye-catching accessory flavors you can't
resist
you are like your style it's not smoke
it's vapor couture
the new electronic cigarette created
just for you obviously that's just a
sample we found these videos on the
YouTube side of stanford research into
the impact of tobacco advertising and
they have collections of additional ads
if you're interested in watching more if
you're interested in hearing about more
will hear it that about them a little
bit more from this right now sure thank
you Scott so no I think these ads speak
for themselves so my concern is this
kind of a public information environment
that is engendered by this kind of
advertising and the debate in the
controversy that is surrounding
e-cigarettes I just want to take you
back about 60 years ago when a unholy
nexus between Hollywood television
industry and advertising industry try to
exactly the tried this tactic say in
normalizing cigarettes you know in
actually promoting glamour associated
with cigarette smoking Joan Crawford in
our John way Jimmy Dean you know all
these famous actors and actresses were
involved in smoking and promoting
cigarettes in fact one very famous actor
went so far as to say that he will send
Chesterfield cigarettes to all his
friends as a Christmas gift that is
President Ronald Reagan right so if you
go come so if you come fast forward to
70 years now you will see the same
tactics used being used but e-cigarettes
that were used by Big Tobacco sex
celebrity glamour adventure classic
American individualist ethos these are
the same appeals that are being used to
advance this idea that somehow smoking
e-cigarettes can solve a lot of problems
life's problems right and also so our
concern is you know so what either this
notion of promoting cigarettes could
potentially lead to two kinds of
outcomes which is one is normalization
of smoking and two that it could
potentially lead to a gateway effect
that it does it could so as a gateway
right now we don't have evidence for
either one of those hypotheses but it
could potentially happen and and I also
want to say that the other thing we are
concerned about is this Dean wormer
refer to the debate that is taking place
between two camps
in the public health community some of
us are in the middle being hit by the
both camps and and for in you know there
are potentially three kinds of effect
that could occur as a result of this
kind of a debate one is contradiction
and confusion and ambiguity among people
who are listening to this debate and who
start thinking the scientists can never
make up their mind right and if they
start thinking that scientists can never
make up their mind that could
potentially be backlash effects and so
why should I believe them and follow
them when they cannot make up their mind
right and that could potentially have
some kind of a carrier effect as a
doctor nagler and others have shown in
the context of nutrition people may not
actually resort to more decidable risk
behaviors or are not indulge in risky
behaviors because you know they have
this backlash effects you know so there
is a danger that it could potentially
have negative effects as a result of
this debate and controversy that is
taking place in the scientific community
think it's very critical for us as
scientists to come together to
understand the implications of this
debate the implications of these
products particularly the implications
of the marketing of these products I can
I can end by saying the marketing as you
clearly saw is not just directed towards
smokers but it is definitely going to
appeal you know based on the evidence
with other products and other issues it
will appeal to a wide range of people
making it more acceptable thanks ray and
in this to that I think one thing that
we're seeing is this is a trend an issue
that's playing out both here in the
United States and abroad really and with
that we'd like to bring the conversation
around to you David to provide us with a
little bit of international context
thanks Scott well it's certainly true
that countries around the world are
experiencing the same regulatory
challenges in the same debate that you
her Ken described proponents position
e-cigarettes as a life-saving
alternative for smokers opponents
suggest that it's going to increase
smoking by recruiting new people into
the market and of course we have
evidence to support both arguments and I
would suggest that ultimately whether
these products have any
like health benefit or harm will be
dictated by how they're regulated and
right now we have different countries
that provide very different regulatory
models so for the time being the United
States is among the least regulated
models in Canada for example no nicotine
e-cigarettes have been approved for sale
so technically speaking e cigarettes
with nicotine are legal for sale in
Canada now we still have some around two
and a half million Canadians that have
tried these products and that's not
terribly well enforced but in the middle
you have something like the European
Union where they've you cigarettes are
widely available for sale but they've
decided to regulate them like tobacco
products so there are comprehensive bans
on how they're advertised and marketing
they're taxed and there's some level of
product standards and the EU model also
provides some flexibility for member
states so we see that the United Kingdom
for example has developed a regulatory
framework to license e cigarettes and
other nicotine products as medicines and
they actually approve the first product
interestingly as a product developed by
a British American Tobacco subsidiary
but the UK model is very much based on
harm reduction and the principle that
the extent of the regulations should be
proportional to the extent of harm for
the product and what's also interesting
in the UK is at the same time as they've
licensed the product is a medicine
they've also increased their regulation
of conventional products in different
ways so internationally I think some of
the key questions or evidence gaps that
regulators are confronting I would
suggest that the first one is to really
identify the best type of regulation for
minimizing excess risks we know that
these products are harmful we also know
that there are significantly less
harmful than conventional cigarettes but
they vary in terms of what goes in and
what comes out of these products so how
can you regulate to minimize any
avoidable risk and I think regulators
are really asking where product design
is going so these products are evolving
very rapidly and as their ability to
deliver nicotine improves they'll become
more appealing not just as acquitted for
smoker but also potentially for uptake
so we see lots of trying among kids not
a lot of regular use
how will that change if the product
design changes so I now finish off by
just reinforcing what I think is the
importance of international
collaboration we have a series of
natural experiments playing out across
the world in very different regulatory
markets and this is an opportunity for
countries to learn from each other and I
would suggest that this has been
fundamentally important in terms of
tobacco control policies for
conventional products and cigarettes and
I would suggest it's also going to be
very important in terms of developing
effective regulation of ends and
e-cigarettes so a lot of a lot of
questions about regulation a lot a lot
of different approaches we've also seen
one rather surprising thing develop here
in the united states on the regulatory
front and that's been that the nation's
largest tobacco companies had actually
come out in favor of regulating
e-cigarettes and that we have a little
bit of a video that we'd like to show
you on
big tobacco companies have been
advocating for strict rules on
e-cigarettes which they say will give
quality and safety standards but
independent companies say that will make
it more difficult for them to compete
and seal the dominance of big tobacco
this is Martine Geller consumer goods
specialist correspondent for Reuters in
London one of the most dramatic examples
of big tobacco company fishing for
regulations is in the United States with
Reynolds American asking the FDA to ban
what are called open systems or
refillable e-cigarettes if not banning
them then at least having independent
vape shops be regulated as manufacturers
independent companies see that as a
swipe to them because complying with FDA
regulations will likely be much more
onerous for a small company than for a
big company like Reynolds American so
that obviously this this plays up the
the global discussion on on tobacco
control tobacco usage Howard how would
you how'd you like to tie that in well I
think one very positive outcome from
this controversy about e-cigarettes is
as brought renewed attention back to the
issue of tobacco control as the leading
preventable public health challenge of
our time unfortunately right now there's
a misperception in the public that
somehow the tobacco problem has been
solved particularly in the United States
it's time to move on to something else
and nothing could be further from the
truth there is no other condition that
kills over half a million Americans
every year there's no other condition
that is projected to kill 1 billion
people worldwide in the 21st century and
so this discussion should be viewed as
part of that broader discussion about
how do we move tobacco control forward
in in this epidemic once and for all now
with respect to e-cigarettes the
advertising and marketing themes that
fish put forward are very very
disconcerting and we should make sure
that everybody knows that big tobacco
has jumped in with both feet here in the
United States on the e cig
theme the major american tobacco
companies Altria Philip Morris Reynolds
American and lorillard all now have
their e-cigarette products I they see
this as part of their future they're
reinventing themselves in this way and
by using the advertising that you have
seen and witnessed even today they are
using themes that were successful for
them before applying it to the
e-cigarette market and in that way
literally going back to the future so we
had to watch this very very carefully as
we try to push tobacco control forward
both in this country in the world one
okay great and obviously you know when
you get into the question of regulation
you need you need ideas you need some
framework to model it around and I'd
like to turn that back to you can now
can you give us some ideas of you know
what policymakers should be be
considering in terms of regulatory
approaches for e-cigarettes uh sure I'd
like to start by saying that I think
they've hit the proverbial nail on the
head when he said that we have to have
the extent of regulations be
proportional to the harm of the product
Howard mentioned earlier on that
currently the FDA has authority to
regulate cigarette smoke less tobacco
and loose tobacco but not the novel
products the fact is FDA has done not
much of anything with regard to the
regulation of the products it's had the
authority to regulate since the
beginning of the law so the deeming
regulations I think are very important
to give them the opportunity to regulate
these alternative products I think the
regulatory barriers just the bureaucracy
the obviously the political opposition
the industry the lawsuits are going to
make any regulation difficult having
said that this is what I would like to
see in the form of what I get I like to
refer to as enlightened regulation we
need regulation it will focus on
minimizing the risks at the same time
that it increases maximizes the benefits
the problem here and this is something
nobody seems to be willing to talk about
is anything that's going to be made
attractive to adults to help them to
quit smoking hopefully is going to
attract some kids
there's going to be this externality if
you will this negative side effect of
making the product attractive for adults
but we need to do that if it's going to
have any benefit to them the reason that
nicotine replacement therapy products
are not terribly attractive to kids
aren't used by kids is it's not
attractive to adults they're not helping
a large they're not helping a large
number of them at this stage that's just
the fact but what would I like to see
I'd like to see us prohibit the emission
of dangerous substances clearly
dangerous substances use the cleaner
forms of vaping and there are some of
those on I very much agree on the idea
of restricting marketing I Eric
lindbloom recently proposed a
restriction of marketing and the form of
direct-to-consumer marketing to adult
smokers that's an interesting idea that
needs some attention get rid of the
lifestyle advertising fish mentioned the
advertising is focused very much on
groups other than those it should be
targeting I've asked e-cigarette
companies where are the ads that are
targeting the 50 and 60 year old smokers
I don't see those I see them targeting
20 and 30 year olds and hence kids and
those people are trying to stop smoking
people are trying to stop smoking are
the 50 and 60 year olds that's where
they should be focused prohibit sales to
minors of course I believe personally
that vaping should not be permitted
where smoking is not permitted and I
don't really care whether the health
consequences are severe or not i think
the non-smokers rights should
predominate over the smokers or the
vapors and because kids are more price
sensitive than adults I would like to
see tax imposed on e-cigarettes and
other vaping products but it should only
be done if the tax on cigarettes and
other combustible tobacco products is
much much higher we want to text that we
want to make the price take it out of
the realm of where kids are going to be
attracted to it and but put it into a
perspective that adults are going to
find adult smokers are going to find
these alternative products relatively
speaking more attractive
and then finally and this gets to
something we haven't talked about yet I
hope that eventually FDA will move
toward a policy that reduces requires
reduction of nicotine and combusted
tobacco products to levels it would not
sustain addiction ironically where this
policy adopted it would give smokers
something that the industry has claimed
all along that they want and that's to
smoke for pleasure rather than a
physiological compulsion to do so that
policy would be aided if there were a
number of good alternative nicotine
delivery systems available for smokers
to move to great interesting set of
policy recommendations wish I understand
that you've written some of your own
could you walk us through some of the
highlights sure so the american
association for cancer research and the
American Society for Clinical Oncology
work together to come out with a giant
position statement on e-cigarettes and
we the task force made a number of
recommendations both in terms of
research as well as policy and I think
can most of what Ken said were also
reiterated in that position statement
except the one on taxes so I think the
the conclusion and the premise is that
much of what we want to know about
e-cigarettes and much of what we want to
do about e-cigarettes can be done under
a much tighter regulatory environment
than the loose innate environment that
we have today so as if we can if FDA can
take charge and start regulation then we
can pursue research in a more systematic
way and a couple of things about that
one I will just highlight a couple of
them one is there are about you know
5,000 different flavors of e-cigarettes
and almost 500 different brands so there
is no standardized to back ecigarette
product so we really don't know what
people are vaping right so that provides
a challenge to us to understand the
physiological impact of e-cigarettes on
on people sell so the one is I think you
know people should be able to
Porter company should be forced to
report the ingredients in these e
cigarette so that we know what is
actually being done or being imperfect
or imbibed by people second I think you
know others have said it on this panel
restricting marketing is extremely
important and critical this is much more
important than it was in 1940s and 50s
precisely because our information
environment is much more different today
we have a variety of different channels
and eat enough with the internet with
social media with webs website with
blogs that we are able to really
customize and target these messages for
different audiences so I think that
makes it much more dangerous and potent
and it makes it that much more urgent to
take control of the marketing and
advertising environment so that we can
minimize the harm I think ok great so
obviously you know product with a
potential for harm perhaps and some
potential for some public health benefit
in certain circumstances von talk a
little bit about what you see as being
the being the potentials here well I
think how it got it exactly right what's
at stake here is is absolutely enormous
in public health terms for almost half a
million Americans per year and
potentially this this century 1 billion
deaths globally it's a problem that we
need to get right we need to bring the
science to bear to make good decisions
now to protect the public health from
from this from the tobacco epidemic any
cigarettes may be an invaluable tool in
helping us to accomplish that if
regulated correctly so some of the
issues can laid out some important
factors you know restricting sales to
minors restricting placing restrictions
throughout advertising and particularly
that the question around price is an
important one we need to and we can
clean ecigarettes up we're starting to
get a better understanding about the
constituents that are any cigarettes
that are preventable or avoidable and we
can find ways to deliver nicotine to
consumers more clearly than what we're
currently doing toxic heavy metals
volatile organic compounds fine
particles can all be eliminated through
the development of better technology
in line with that we're thinking about
developing better product standards but
having better regulation over the way
the product is is both designed and
manufactured in order to perform in
specific ways to reduce the harm to the
consumer while promoting effective clean
nicotine delivery one of the things that
we're very interested in is the
potential for e-cigarettes to promote
nicotine dependence we know that
conventional tobacco cigarettes are very
good at promoting tobacco dependence
it's very difficult for a conventional
tobacco smoker to switch to an
e-cigarette if they're not delivering
adequate amounts of nicotine in other
words e-cigarettes need to deliver
comparable amounts of nicotine in a
similar way as a conventional product in
order for them to be a viable
alternative to a conventional tobacco
cigarette what so if I may interrupt you
briefly because there's some tension
between what you're sketching out what
what ken talked about where it seems
like we are we talking about a need to
have enough but not too much nicotine is
that though we need to make we need to
deliver enough nicotine in a way that
satisfactory to a smoker to make it a
viable alternative to discourage
conventional smokers from using both
products over an extended period of time
if we're going to see harm reduction
benefits smokers need to switch
completely from tobacco cigarettes to an
e-cigarette and that can be accomplished
through better technology and better
development of regulatory product
standards at the same time e cigarette
regulation needs to be considered in the
context of current tobacco regulations
and there are strategies in front of the
FDA now potentially to reduce nicotine
delivery and conventional cigarette
products so just as we can set up a
gradient in price making the an
e-cigarette more favorable to to
consumers compared with a conventional
tobacco product we might set up a
gradient of nicotine delivery of
pleasure of satisfaction that favors
e-cigarettes compared with conventional
tobacco products by reducing nicotine
delivery and conventional tobacco
cigarettes and reducing those other
additives and constituents which make
products easy to use and appealing to
consumers particularly to youth
and inherent in all of this argument is
removing flavors that appeal to kids in
e-cigarettes it's an absolutely critical
regulatory strategy that needs to be
addressed by FDA okay all all points
obviously as you say that speak to
regulation that speak to the FDA and
we'd like to bring it back to you David
tell us a little bit about some areas
where you'd like to see the FDA Act well
I think that you've heard the others
mention them which is the first priority
is probably to try and position these
products not as the starter products and
you heard Ken and others talk about how
advertising and marketing restrictions
are critical restrictions on flavors and
access so you know there are more and
more jurisdictions both nationally at
the sub-national level that are starting
to implement you know sales ban to
minors so I think those are all
important starting points and those you
know even for proponents for proponents
of these products you see a big public
health impact I think the best thing you
can do for the product is actually to
try and sever that tie with youth as
much as possible so I think that's an
area where there's probably consensus on
both sides of the aisle and probably
some move for immediate action in terms
of the FDA you know the issue about what
is the optimal level of nicotine
delivery for these products that's much
trickier as I said before the very
features that make them appealing as a
product to switch from cigarettes or to
use as a quid aid are potentially the
same characteristics that make them more
appealing to use as well as an uptake
product so you know we see very high
levels of trying in encounter that's
actually similar to the US where it's
about you know fifth of all of our youth
and young adults or try any cigarettes
very very few of those are actually
going on to use those products for any
sustained period but that's not a fixed
that's not a fixed entity that could
very much change as these products
evolve so fortunate in the u.s. you have
among the best scientists in the world
and the resources to monitor the product
very carefully and I think that'll be
very important for the FDA to facilitate
moving forward okay great well I think
so far we've had some some really great
ideas and some valuable insights and at
this point we
like to turn it off turn this over to me
to the audience to hear some of your
thoughts will get to you folks in the
room but we're going to start with the
people online thanks Scott and I do just
want to say we have a very active chat
going on right now a lot of questions
coming in but I want to take one that's
come in from Reuters with some breaking
news just a few minutes ago the CDC
posted surprising new data on e
cigarette and tobacco use among us teens
electronic cigarette used some Hmong us
middle and high school students tripled
in 2014 while smoking of conventional
cigarettes fell by nearly twenty-five
percent how does this new information
change the regulatory equation is this
cause for alarm that youngsters are
taking up the new devices so rapidly or
a new sign that e-cigarette use can
reduce tobacco consumption so that just
came in in interesting and relevant to
our discussion well I would start by
saying that's not surprising news we
know the rates are going up dramatically
among young people and so this just
confirms that trend so it's accelerating
there's also a very important report
from monitoring the future last year
saying that among high school students
more high school students are not trying
ye cigarettes in the last month as
opposed to traditional cigarettes so
this just underscores the urgency of
getting our arms around this problem
getting the regulation process going
both federally and also accelerating at
the state local level and then doing
that in a informed manner with the best
research so if this can be used as a
form of harm reduction we can get there
sooner rather than later and put that
all within the context of this very
important global conversation on how to
accelerate tobacco control Scott can you
go in to chime in yeah go again yeah
Howard started out saying exactly what I
was thinking this isn't surprising
because the data from monitoring the
future have indeed shown is the same
thing the new day to demonstrate
something absolutely fascinating the
decrease in smoking among the kids
surveyed in 2014 when we saw this huge
jump in ecigarettes was the largest
within
memory if you look at the fact we've
been seeing declining smoking among kids
year after year for a long number of
years now last year was the biggest one
we've perhaps ever seen in terms of
percentage points I don't know what that
means but the questioner has something
we need to ask ourselves is there some
sort of substitution going on are people
who would have been smokers or were
smoking are these kids are these
substituting e-cigarettes for that and
then Dave's point is really a critical
one as well is this something of a fad
or is this going to become a long-term
sustained trend so there's many
questions raised by these data as there
are answers and we don't know whether
this is a good bad or indifferent thing
at this stage vana I'd like to get your
input on this thing because one of the
things that strikes me with this this
new data is that you know while I knew
you've almost all maybe all of you
spoken about you know the desire to keep
this product out of the hands of kids on
the other hand we also know that really
throughout their lives well throughout
the population teens do partake in some
risky behaviors that maybe we'd rather
not see them do but if they're going to
do them we want to see them do it in a
safer way is there a is there a harm
reduction lesson here or a framework to
be thinking about this well we have to
think into in terms of harm reduction
about what we're reducing harm from and
and with teens the the objective is to
prevent initiation in the first place so
so the harm reduction debate is not so
relevant as it is is the question of
preventing youth initiation and and that
the later weekend or that the longer we
can prevent youth initiation the later
the age of initiation the less likely
youth will be will will mature to become
dependent users of tobacco products so I
think that's an important strategy
there's there's clearly good news and
bad news in the CDC data and I think we
want to think very carefully about how
we can continue to undermine or prevent
youth access or interest in e-cigarettes
because we're concerned about the
potential for that to develop into other
forms of
better use they shall you yeah you know
this also i think these data both can
inhabit said reinforce what muck the
monitoring the future study has shown
clearly you know the youth are not
picking out of picking up this habit out
of thin air right and also we just saw
very glamorous advertising trying to
communicate a certain kind of
aspirational messages you know to the
youth that is the question to ask a
reason is what kind of information are
they getting about e-cigarettes and and
to what extent is this larger
information environment influencing them
to pick up this habit we savvy other
kinds of habits i think so this this
actually reinforces you know the
importance of placing some restrictions
on advertising and marketing towards the
youth okay did we have another question
from the online yes yes we do we have a
lot of them i'm going to try to pick
ones that are representative of others
mr. Kenneth Warner mentioned that there
are toxic substances in some e-cigs not
in others besides the known nicotine
what might some of those be can you
expound on this I'm probably not the
right person to try to give you a list
of them because I'm not a biological or
chemical scientist I and I hope I may
have said that there are other that some
of these cigarette products aren't as
dangerous that's what I hope I said that
they're not as dangerous as others
because they're not admitting some of
these heavy metals and the like I hope I
didn't say that any of them were giving
off only nicotine because I don't think
we know that Vaughn may have better
knowledge of this than I do but there's
a huge array of substances that come out
of different vaping products that's
right not and I think you know this
underscores the need for regulation to
engage in surveillance of e cigarette
products so that we do know what's in
them and with effective product
standards manufacturers will be required
to ensure that products are kept to keep
harmful constituents at an absolute
minimum and report that to a regulatory
authority such as FDA
great great I think I'll take one more
and then we'll see if anyone here has
questions I'm sure you do we are getting
a lot of questions from Canada I just
want everyone to know in the past
tobacco users denoted the use of tobacco
on insurance policy applications more
recently it is shown that those who use
e-cigarettes are denoting that no they
do not use tobacco but through health
exams it is revealed that nicotine is
present in their systems how will the
insurance industry need to change
theories of thinking when it comes to
this product maybe I can start on there
there are debates about exactly what do
we turn these products and you probably
know that several years ago the FDA
tried to regulate e-cigarettes as
delivery devices and that was struck
down in court and actually a judge ruled
that this could be now potentially
regulated as a tobacco product so that's
what gave FDA the motivation to move
forward with this proposed deeming rule
so this is now accepted as a tobacco
product by definition although some
might debate that including the
insurance plans that you just cited I
think the more we call this a tobacco
product treat it like a tobacco product
make that uniform throughout all our
discussions whether it's with health
insurance or other themes the more we
can make progress in this whole area
thank you you do want to take one from
the room
one perspective that hasn't been
mentioned yet is which all particularly
just a second gets his motivation from
looking steadily at the facts that both
Howard lon mentioned that a billion
people may die in this century from
tobacco and that elimination of tobacco
is a single most powerful intervention
that is feasible for improving
population health something that the
public doesn't think about steadily now
given that this is what motivates the
idea of the tobacco endgame of severing
tobacco from the human race once and for
all in getting rid of this greatest of
threats if if the if the the e-cigarette
were wording there were replaced by
Ebola people would think why of course
you should regulate whatever look Ebola
is a terrible threat to us they have no
idea that tobacco is vastly more
threatening to the human race than Ebola
is now in one of those ads the the word
that really got my attention was not and
there's no stigma but achieving a stigma
for the use of tobacco has been one of
the fantastic victory so they
anti-tobacco movement and the the the
picture were given here is of these
glamorous youth smoking in public
without any sense of stigma at all which
would be giving up one of the great
achievements that's been a hard fought
for and won in the United States ten
steps back even if ecigarettes are not
all that dangerous still it takes away
the sting most smoking so I'm this this
idea of a tobacco end game is not one
that we're where the public health
community is thinking about the same
goals as the public is certainly not
that you cigarette industry and so it's
hard to debate put this into the debate
because they just reject the premise
what do you think
okay I'll start I mean there are many
there are many questions and themes in
there and so let me just start by saying
you know vicious point that the tobacco
industry is basically renormalized
smoking through pushing the e-cigarette
product is very very disturbing for
public health from a broad perspective
on the other hand we we are now talking
about a potential end game last year was
the 50th anniversary of the landmark
surgeon general's report on tobacco from
1964 it was there was a a summit at the
White House I had the great honor of
being there in my role as assistant
secretary for health and leaders like
Ken Warner and others where they are
talking about can we see a time sooner
rather than later aware we can stop
sales of tobacco in certain places where
we can see tobacco products in this
country put forward with nicotine levels
that are less than addictive these are
points that can just raised shortly
after that we saw CBS announced that
they're going to stop selling tobacco
throughout all their stories United
States and they've named their
organization CBS health so that that was
part of a in game strategy if you will
so it's very very important to keep this
conversation going and we don't need the
renormalization of tobacco when the
midst of this to get us to the goal of
ending this epidemic and that's where we
all need to go in this country and
worldwide you know I want to put this in
a larger context to if you look at it in
the 20th century hundred million people
died of tobacco related deaths right
that's in a one third of the US
population today six million people die
of tobacco-related users globally eighty
percent of these deaths come from low
and middle-income countries I think so
we don't have to we should not just
limit our conversation only to the US I
think this these renormalization effort
these efforts to create a sense of
glamour association with adventure
independence actually have an impact
beyond United States you know because of
the dominance of American cultural
industry globally
so we once when we talked about in our
restricting marketing advertising the
beneficiaries are not just the youth in
the United States you know but also I
think in other countries who are
continuously exposed to these kinds of
messages I think so it's very critical
for us to think about this process of
renormalization while protecting if
there are if the question is if if there
are any public health benefits in
e-cigarettes we can continue to do that
we can continue with that process under
it tightly regulated environment without
the necessity of this kind of marketing
great can I jump in on that as well I
would just add that you know one of the
things that these products are doing is
forcing us to be a bit more nuanced in
terms of what we talked about tobacco I
mean it's it's the mode of delivery it's
ingesting tobacco through smoke that is
responsible for most of the harm and so
you know it's it's forcing us to think
about denormalization of smoking versus
denormalization of other forms of
nicotine intake so we don't denormalize
the use of the patch of the gum in other
words nicotine intake through the mouth
of the skin the same way that we do
through smoke and so I think the goal
needs to remain very much squarely
focused on denormalization of smoking
and to the extent that that we want to
think about how e-cigarettes and
vaporized nicotine is positioned well I
think that comes back to what we talked
about in terms of restrictions on
marketing and labeling so we've done
some work on that and it's marketing
advertising bands it's labeling of the
products themselves that very much
shapes the norm along with mass media
campaigns and so there's a possibility
to sort of shape the norm of smoking and
vaporized nicotine products in a
deliberate way and I think the debate is
going to be about what we want to do and
how we shape those products relative to
each other can I can i chime in I'd like
to reinforce with both Dave and Howard
and others are saying here I I do think
I do think the two critical regulatory
elements here are marketing and public
place use if we want to talk about d
normal as a
I also think in regard to the speaker's
question what has made this issue so
difficult is the differentiation between
smoked or combusted tobacco products and
other tobacco products I howard
mentioned it's just been a little over a
year since the release of the 50th
anniversary Surgeon General's report we
seem to have forgotten one of the
principal messages that came out of that
report which is that the enemy here is
combusted tobacco and we need to focus
laser-like on combusted tobacco that's
not to say that oral tobacco use in some
parts of the world like India and the
Sudan is not a very serious problem but
in some countries like Sweden it may
have been part of the solution of the
tobacco disease problem so snus which is
a form of smokeless tobacco that's been
used for four decades or more by males
in Sweden has led to the finding that
this will use tobacco about the same
levels as other European countries but
they don't smoke much they use snus and
if you look at their rates of death from
one cancer tobacco-related heart disease
overall mortality associated with
tobacco they are dramatically lower than
the second best country in each of those
categories in all of the European Union
so this is a complicated issue because
it's not a matter of I mean we can waive
our hand to say let's get rid of all
tobacco I think everybody in public
health one would want to do that back
has been with us for two millennia and
it's not about to go away overnight and
we just need to keep that much one more
thing I'd to say is very quickly because
I think this is important for people to
recognize a colleague David Mendes and I
have a model simulation model by which
we've been projecting smoking prevalence
in the United States since the mid-1990s
the model has been extremely accurate
through the year 2010 the last time we
checked uh if we don't do anything
different from what we're doing today it
is plausible that we will have smoking
prevalence above ten percent in the
United States in the year 2050 that's
frightening prospect that's why we've
got to start thinking about these
endgame notions and the subtleties of
sloped versus non smoked and so on
dramatic projections do we have thinks I
don't think we have time but there are a
lot of questions online i encourage
everyone to go on because i know we want
to hear your closing okay so just to it
to wrap it up I'd like each of you to
make just one brief and try to keep it
brief because we are tight on time here
policy recommendation start with you
Vaughn and work your way down the line
thank you well I think we can all see
that we have an amazing opportunity here
but we need to protect the public health
gains that we've that we've gained over
the past half-century it seems that
there might be a sweet spot in terms of
regulation we need to continue to
discourage youth from adopting
e-cigarettes we need to maintain
denormalization of use of tobacco
products we can accomplish that through
effective marketing strategies
imposition of tax policy we also need to
impose product standards which helped to
make ecigarettes a more viable
alternative in a safer alternative to as
safe as they can be and a better
alternative to then combustible tobacco
cigarettes my final message for everyone
watching is keep the discussion on
tobacco control alive this is still an
ever-present overwhelming public health
threat for all of us in this country and
worldwide this cigarette conversation
can be very healthy if it keeps us
exploring how best to get to the end
game and yet and the epidemic dish agree
i think you know i don't know people on
this side of the table and other side of
the table as well as those who are on
the TV I don't want us to sit 30 years
from now again and meet and say we made
a mistake you know we did not know what
we were doing I think that's exactly
what happened and now in the with a
cigarette was a tobacco problem earlier
so I think it's extremely important
extremely urgent to really eliminate
this problem of tobacco you know
globally because it's just not for the
US you know there are serious
significant implicit implications all
over the globe Grayson ken I don't think
I need to add anything to the very
astute comments of my colleagues here
I'd agree with them David last word goes
to you if you want it
I would just suggest that we need to
think about the range of tobacco and
nicotine products collectively together
and we need to regulate them with an eye
on what regulation to one set of
products what the implications might be
for the other set of products and I
would just hang on because it's going to
be a crazy ride in terms of regulatory
experimentation than them with very high
stakes for public health well this crazy
ride I'm afraid has come to me however
online i do encourage you to keep the
conversation going on twitter and end on
the forum on and also i want you to
think about tuning in for our next event
it's going to be May fifteenth to Friday
and it's going to focus on how new
technologies are transforming health
care here at the forum with that thank
you all for your time it's been a
pleasure
you